Americans say they lost nearly
one-and-a-half billion dollars to fraud
last year now a quickly growing phone
scam is targeting banking customers via
your text messages so in one version of
that scam a scammer pretends to be with
the bank's fraud department and ask
about a fake suspicious withdrawal our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
here so what makes this key I could see
how people could fall for this if you
think your bank is calling asking you
about something what makes this one so
unique
well these scammers are getting extra
sophisticated many of us safeguard
sensitive accounts from being hacked by
using that those extra measures like
text message verification to sign-in but
one man tells the scammer subverted that
process and even used his bank's actual
phone number to text him no lady
identified her as Cindy at my particular
bank and told me there had been a fraud
attempt on my account everything seemed
normal when Peter Gunz answered a call
earlier this month that he says appeared
to come from his bank the caller asked
guns who lives in California if he had
attempted a transaction in Miami after
gun said no she asked for his bank
member identification and he gave it to
her and at that point the lady said okay
we're gonna send you a one time
verification pen so we can check your
identity the scammer then used his bank
member ID to prompt a text message from
the bank's real phone number like others
he'd received before with that one time
verification code gun stret it back over
the phone which allowed the scammer to
access his account and list off actual
bank transactions the fact that they
used the bank's own infrastructure to
send that pin code to me which then
allowed them to reset my password made
it very credible it was only when the
scammer asked guns for his bank PIN
number that he realized something was
wrong hung up and called the bank's real
fraud line to lock his account a lot of
scams come in through the phone and more
and more we're seeing them coming in
through text message
Catherine Hutt is with the Better
Business Bureau she says some red flags
include if any caller asked for your
name address social security number or
account numbers
and the best way to make sure you're
really talking to your bank just call
the number on your card whether it's a
small local community bank or credit
union or one of the biggest banks in the
country they can be impostor and so you
just have to be really careful guns
choose a technology lawyer later tweeted
about the scam he told us several people
responded to him with similar stories
the Better Business Bureau says it's a
best practice to regularly monitor your
bank statements for potentially
fraudulent charges I was just recently
hacked were you really like check my
account
very closely yeah and that's how I was
able to detect it so it's now being
investigated but there's so many ways I
mean whether this is really
sophisticated you think they're trying
to help you that was a call you got to
make a phone call a phone call and and
if they ask you for information about
what's your ID number or your password
or your account number because if
they're really the bank they should know
what your account is right oh absolutely
yeah I could see people I could see
falling for that in the heat of the
moment help you good thing he pulled up
tarika thank you very much